20 years ago Tang xinhwa left her home
in China south to work as a cleaner in
Beijing
she promised to return at least once a
year and she did until 2020 when the
government imposed covid-19 restrictions
on travel
now those have ended she's making the
journey again with her granddaughter and
daughter in towel
my parents kept asking when we would
return but because the outbreak we
couldn't but they didn't understand they
kept a saying make sure you come this
year I tried my best to explain the
rules one thing is for sure they miss us
very much
[Music]
the family will reunite to celebrate the
Lunar New Year China's most important
annual holiday
it's the first time two-year-old Liao ee
will meet her great-grandparents
they are among the tens of millions of
Migrant workers traveling across China
this week known here is it's the world's
largest animal Migration of people and
like Tang XI many have not seen their
relatives for years it's been three
years since this train station was this
busy people of all ages all walks of
life are beginning their Journey entire
families are on the move
the government says 2.1 billion trips
will be made Nationwide this month
that's double last year's number
returning home and the tourism are the
two main reasons for traveling there is
a big increase in terms of total trips
the numbers of Travelers Nationwide it
won't quite reach pre-pandemic levels
but as the restrictions relax further
and the economy recovers there will be
more movement
and people aren't only traveling
domestically the end of mandatory
quarantine for incoming passengers has
led to an increase in ticket sales for
international flights many are flying to
Southeast Asia avoiding countries with
virus restrictions on travelers from
China such as Japan and the United
States
has never left the country but her
journey is longer than most
after 28 hours on a train they arrive in
rural Sichuan Province meeting her
elderly parents who have recently
recovered from the Coronavirus
for their health and the presence of
four generations Under One Roof she says
there's much to celebrate
Katrina Al Jazeera Beijing
[Music]